Jack and Maga is probably the most
confusing Game of Thrones character like
first he's in a cage then he's a soldier
and he kills people for ire and gives
her a coin and changes his face and goes
away then three seasons later in Braavos
there's this old guy who's actually
jackin but he says he's not Jack and
then he dies then he's still alive then
he's like you are how no one in the
books things are different again Jack
and isn't at the house of black and
white in Braavos but he does turn up at
the Citadel at Old Town disguised as an
alchemist and there all these theories
all these connections jackin and the
faceless men have with Euron Greyjoy
dragons and Valyria some people even
think that Jack and maybe Syrio Forel so
let's work this stuff out what's going
on with Jack and Hegar in bulking season
2 aya joins a group of Nights Watch
recruits led by Yoram most of them are
prisoners from the dungeons of King's
Landing and three of these are
considered so dangerous that they're
kept chained up in the back of a wagon
there's biter a monstrous man with
pointed teeth Raj a brute with no nose
and then there's Jack and Hegar a
handsome smiling polite man who says
he's from the city of lorath jaqen is
nice - aya asks her phobia tells her she
could make a friend later when the group
is attacked Jack and Rajan biters wagon
catches fire and aya saves them from the
flames by bringing an axe to break their
chains
when ire is taken to Harrenhal Jack and
turns up again apparently having joined
under the Lannisters as a mercenary Jack
and tells aya that since she saved him
and Raj and bita from the fire the red
God is owed three lives so Jack and
offers to kill three people for her once
this death debt is paid Jack and says
his time is done he magically changes
his face into another man's taking on a
whole new identity the name Jack and the
face the manner of speech the whole
personality is revealed to be a lie the
truth is that this person is an assassin
of the faceless men the faceless men are
a secretive society of assassins you pay
them and they'll kill someone for you
this had to be very expensive but very
effective when I adjoins the faceless
men at their base in the house of black
and white in Braavos we learned that the
faceless man aren't just assassins
they're also priests who worship death
they believe that every different
religion has some figure that represents
death so they call death the many-faced
God when jaqen was talking about the red
God before he was talking about the Lord
of Light as a face of the many-faced God
one of many aspects of death the
faithless often speak of death as a gift
a mercy a release from the suffering of
life so the assassinations they carry
out seem sacred to them as assassins
faceless men are trained to use
deception perception poison and sticks
to kill their targets they use human
faces to magically disguise themselves
as other people and they're trained to
give up their identities their hopes and
dreams loves and hates everything that
makes them who they are to become a
faceless man you must become no one
which makes things very confusing it
means that when we talk about jaqen
H'ghar we're actually talking about a
faceless man who happens to wear jack
ins face but apparently any faceless man
can wear any face there's this stuff in
the show where a man who appears to be
Jack and drinks poison and dies and then
the waif wears Jerkins face and then
another man turns up as Jack and later
so the faceless men seem interchangeable
almost like a hive mind any of them can
be anyone because they're all no one so
it's probably best to think of jaqen as
just an extension of the faceless man a
servant of the many-faced God but what's
he actually up to Jack and makes a big
effort to recruit ire to the faceless
men he turns up just when she's feeling
weak and afraid and shows her that
killing can make her feel strong and
brave by letting her pick 3 of her
enemies to kill Jack and gives her a
taste of the power of being a faceless
assassin
never mind that a real faceless assassin
doesn't get to pick their own targets he
shows off by changing his face in front
of her and that's when he tells her to
come with him to Braavos to learn the
same magic as though the house of black
and white was more Hogwarts than death
cult he fails to mention all the
downsides of being with the faceless
like living in a Stone Temple scrubbing
corpses daily beatings and you know
Oh completely giving up your identity to
become no.1 Jack ins like some slimy
army recruiter he manipulates aiya into
joining the faceless men and some fans
believe this was his mission all along
maybe that the manipulation begins with
Syrio Forel
Syrio Forel is the Braavosi swordsman
who trains Iyer in King's Landing and he
teaches her many of the same things that
jackin and the faceless men teach how to
be sneaky how to stand very still to see
things as they truly are and that
violence can make her feel strong
Syria's training is like the perfect
introduction to a later training with
the faceless men like how to be badass
101 before the more advanced badassery
at the house of black and white in the
show Syrio tells aya there is only one
God and His name is death which lines up
with what jaqen says later there is only
one God a girl knows his name so the
theory here is that the reason for these
connections and similarities between
Syria and Jachin is that Syria is Jaken
another false face of the faceless men
who came to King's Landing specifically
to Train ayah and recruiter as a
faceless assassin which could maybe be
possible the last time we saw Syria it
looks like he's about to be killed by
Meryn Trant but maybe he actually
escapes and somehow ends up in the black
cells with the face of Jack and Hagar in
time to be recruited to the Nights Watch
in the same group with aya but why would
Serio slash jaqen deliberately get
himself locked up in the black cells and
in that cage that almost got him killed
surely he could have found another way
to stick with aya if that was his goal
and if it wasn't deliberate then he got
locked up by mistake it's a pretty big
coincidence that he just happened to be
recruited into the same group Arya was
traveling with so either way this
doesn't make much sense
and what about Syria himself like did
the faceless man seriously kill and
replace the first sword of Braavos yah
so they could train a random Westerosi
nine-year-old desire really such an
amazing potential assassin to be worth
all this hassle and how would the
faceless man even know about her do they
have spies at Winterfell the more you
think about it the less sense it makes
for Serio to be jaqen the more likely
explanation is that the reason why
serios trained
fits with jack ins is because this is a
story it needs to fit it needs to have a
flow to it
Aya's arc explores themes of violence
and loss of identity so naturally she
meets mentors who gradually guide her
down that path not every character has a
secret identity but some of them do The
Alchemist is a mysterious character we
see in feast at Old Town he makes a deal
with a guy named pate a novice at the
Citadel where maced as a trained the
alchemist gives paid a gold piece in
return for a certain key a key said to
be able to unlock every door in the
Citadel but hold almost nothing about
the alchemist but we do get a
description of his face a description
that happens to perfectly match the new
face that Jack and wears after he leaves
Harrenhal full cheeks a hooked nose a
scar on the right cheek and curly black
hair the alchemist is another false
identity of the faceless men probably
the same man as Jaken
so in feast this alchemist gets his key
and then he appears to kill pate but
later when Sam arrives in old town he
meets paid alive and well but there are
some weird things about him the clue
suggests that this pate is actually the
alchemists in disguise who is probably
actually Jack and in disguise who is
actually a faceless man in disguise and
now this babushka or assassin is bunking
with Sam Tali in old town holding a key
said to be able to unlock every door in
the Citadel but why what do the faceless
men want in the Citadel were given one
clue in dance tyrion mentions a book a
fragmentary anonymous blood-soaked tome
called blood and fire or the death of
dragons the only surviving copy of which
is supposedly hidden away in a locked
vault beneath the Citadel when Pete
gives the alchemist the key he
specifically wonders if the alchemist
might want a book locked down in the
vaults of the Citadel so the clues
suggest that the faceless man wants this
book but why are the faceless men
interested in dragons in feast the
kindly man tells aya how the faceless
men began his story goes back thousands
of years to the Valyria
Freehold the empire of the original
dragon lords who ruled most of the known
world through the power of their dragons
and their slaves
the kindly man tells of the slaves who
worked in the mines beneath the volcanic
mountains called the 14 flames
these mines were so hot and the work so
hard that slaves would pray for an end
to their pain and the first faceless man
was someone who gave them that gift who
killed the slaves who suffered the most
ayah says they should have killed the
slave masters not the slaves and the
kindly man says he would bring the gift
to them as well but that is a tale for
another day so the kindly man is
suggesting that the faceless man brought
the gift of death to the slave masters
of Valyria and some readers believe this
refers to the doom of Valyria the
massive fiery catastrophe that suddenly
destroyed the Empire 400 years ago the
doom is mysterious no one really knows
what caused it but maybe the faceless
men were behind it killing all the slave
masters their slaves and the entire
empire in one huge terrible sacrament to
the many-faced God of death there's no
strong evidence for this but it totally
could fit and it could maybe explain why
the faceless men now want this book
about dragons because of course there
were survivors of the doom the Targaryen
family and their dragons escaped Valyria
and went on to conquer Westeros ruling
the Seven Kingdoms for centuries until
their overthrow by Robert eventually
leaving Daenerys the last of the
Dragonlords and now she's rising as a
queen conquering cities across slavers
Bay and unlike the Targaryen zuv the
last hundred or so years danny has
dragons given the history with Valyria
the faceless men are probably not too
keen for a new dragon queen with the
blood of old Valyria so maybe they want
to stop her maybe they want to kill her
dragons and maybe that's why jaqen is
stealing a book called the death of
dragons
there are a lot of maybes here and there
are problems with the idea for one thing
Dany is ending slavery in the cities
that she captures and it seems like
slavery is kind of the main problem that
the faceless man had with Valyria
also if the faceless men are so against
Valyrian
targaryen so you'd think they would have
moved against them sometime in the last
300 years of Targaryen rule in Westeros
maybe they did somehow at this point we
just don't know but this history with
Illyria seems important either way
another big thing is that in book 3 we
hear that Balin Greyjoy father of Theon
and Asha has died fallen from a bridge
at Pike during a storm in the show we
see baylin's brother Euron is the one to
kill him attacking him and pushing him
off the bridge but in the books it's
different in a sample chapter of winds
Euron admits to killing Baylon but says
he didn't do the deed himself so who did
well earlier in book 3 the ghost of hai
Hart has a dream of a man without a face
waiting on a bridge that sways and
swings on his shoulder perches a drowned
crow with seaweed hanging from his wings
the drowned crow sounds like urine crows
eye and the man without a face sounds
like a faceless man so it sounds like
you're on hired a faceless man to kill
Baylon maybe Jaken was the one to do it
after he went to Harrenhal but there's
another complication because remember
the faceless men are expensive and
George Mardan says that the cost of
hiring a faceless assassin depends on
how important and hard to kill the
target is so if you're on hired a
faceless man to kill King Balin Greyjoy
it must have cost a lot so what could he
have paid them with well in feast Euron
says that he once had a dragon egg but
he couldn't make it hatch so he threw it
into the sea if you're on did have a
dragon egg would he really be stupid
enough to throw away something so
valuable maybe he actually used it as
payment for a faceless assassin to kill
Balaam and maybe the faceless have plans
for this egg because dragon eggs seem to
be powerful magical fiery objects they
were involved in the mysterious tragedy
of summerhall where a fire got out of
control and killed a bunch of Targaryen
forty years ago fans speculate that
dragon eggs may have been involved in
other fiery catastrophes like the
destruction of hardhome and maybe the
doom of Valyria we don't know how this
would work exactly and there's no strong
evidence but
is that there definitely are connections
between the faceless men and Valyria and
Dragons and Euron especially when you
look at the most recent sample chapter
of winds called the vas akin in this
chapter which was a reading by George
Martin transcribed by fans we learned
that euron greyjoy is even more evil
than he seemed in the books he always
was creepy and cruel and manipulative
but in this chapter we see an even
darker side to the crow's eye urine has
imprisoned his brother Aron along with a
bunch of other priests from different
religions on his ship and he's torturing
them physically and psychologically in
horrific ly creative ways involving fire
and dismemberment and talk of past
childhood abuse and you're on drugs a
Ron and he has these nightmares of
dragons and Krakens and skulls and dead
gods and we learned Euron's planning
something some kind of sacrifice he's
using the blood of priests and warlocks
and pregnant women on the eve of a naval
battle to cause something terrible
there's imagery of a boiling bloody sea
of a monstrous Cthulhu like you Ron
we're told that blood is power and that
these are the last days when the world
shall be broken and remade a new God
shall be born from the graves and
charnel pits so this is vague but
terrifying and it could possibly connect
to the faceless men who are after all a
literal death cult killing and blood is
kind of their jam and there are some
real connections here like the use of
priests from all different religions is
kind of like the many-faced God and also
all this is happening just off the coast
near Old Town which is where the
faceless Alchemist is we already know
the faithless man worked for Euron to
kill bail on so maybe they're also
conspiring with him to create this great
sacrifice this terrible orgy of death
and blood which may like the doom of
Valyria have cataclysmic consequences
there could be dragon eggs involved the
death of Dragons may be related or maybe
the faceless men have nothing to do with
it we can't say for sure but here's what
we do know
jaqen H'ghar is the false identity of a
faceless man he somehow ended up in the
black cells of King's Landing and then
met Arya and led her to join the
faceless man it's possible that he was
working with Arya all along as Syrio
Forel but that doesn't seem likely we do
know that the alchemist now pate is a
faceless man probably the same one as
jaqen and he seems to be planning to
steal a book about dragons from the
Citadel
we know the faceless men have bad blood
with Valyria which might explain the
interest in the book the death of
Dragons and it seems likely that a
faceless man killed Baylin Greyjoy for
Euron which may have involved a dragon
egg that may relate back to cataclysms
like the doom lastly we know that you
runs planning some terrible sacrifice
which could also somehow relate to
jackin the faceless men and their many
faced God so that probably raised more
questions than it answered but that's
kind of the fun of this character
comment below what you think Jack and
Hagar and the faceless men are up to and
make sure to subscribe if you haven't
already thanks for watching this video
draws a lot from the ideas of the Song
of Ice and Fire fan community so there
are links in the description to some
really great essays and forum posts if
you'd like to have a look
thanks to all supporters on patreon
including katie murphy jeremy cash and
Amy McCracken Thomas McElroy Elijah
rosebery Sybil star Elise Harper Gregory
folk decoy
octopod Teddy ranjan and spike Cheers
you